évidemment thierry valade bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france on le
disait l'intelligence artificielle des
robots des drones de plus en plus
utilisés pour surveiller les frontières
européennes concrètement qui utilisent
ces robots comme en
beaucoup de pays utilisent déjà ces
robots là on vient d'apprendre hier que
l'espagne allait mettre également des
drones pour surveiller les migrants à sa
frontière avec le avec le maroc on a
aujourd'hui des algorithmes qui ont été
utilisés notamment dans le projet dans
l'ain projet contrôle border qui avait
fait polémique puisque ces algorithmes
était supposé détecter des émotions sur
les les personnes qui rentraient dans
l'union européenne pour détecter les
mensonges à une espèce de de détecteur
de mensonges grandeur nature donc ce
projet a été annulé mais en gros on
repousse ce set cette idée avec nouveau
projet qui s'appelle avatar qui est dans
la même la même idée de contrôle des
émotions par des algorithmes
détecteur de mensonge une fois que ces
migrants sont soit interceptée
oui enfin les migrants migrants est en
fait tout entrant dans la dans l'union
européenne on a ce projet dont contre le
border qui avait été expérimenté en
lituanie en grèce fayet trois pays qui
avait été qui avait été expérimenté ça
avait été un acérées important fiasco
mais là on relance on relance le projet
avec avatar qui est de la même la même
nature donc le whist 1 contre e1 un
détecteur de mensonges et on va utiliser
apparemment de plus dans plus de doughty
algorithmique de détecteurs pour
vérifier vérifier la fiabilité la
reconnaissance faciale bien évidemment
il sera en bonne place donc tout ça fait
vraiment froid dans le dos dans une en
un projet quand même qui alors on parle
de déshumanisation là on est vraiment
dans un dans un projet de surveillance
algorithmique de grande ampleur c'est
pour ça que vous parliez de fiasco tout
à l'heure concernant le le projet de
détecteur de mensonges
disons que ce type de projet est
aujourd'hui on le sait très bien avec
les expériences avec le pantographe
américain donc le détecteur de mensonges
première version il ya des billets qui
sont qui sont induits par par les
algorithmes enfin on en entre des les
informations qui ne sont pas qui ne sont
pas détectés par les algorithmes qui
vont privilégier par exemple la la la la
culpabilité personnes qui seraient qui
seront peut-être deux de race noire ou 2
ou 2 ou 2 femmes par rapport par rapport
aux sommes dont kylie a cessé ses
billets déjà cognitif euros à la base et
donc la technologie nenê n'est
absolument pas
valables à 100% comme peut l'être par
exemple adn donc oui je parle de fiasco
parce que cette expérimentation n'a pas
du tout abouti et surtout est
extrêmement intrusive dans les dents les
la vie privée des personnes et ne
correspond absolument pas à une
traitement
humaniser pour revenir à votre
expression d'un d'un migrant ou de ou
d'une personne qui va rentrer dans un
dans un an dans l'espace schengen ou ou
de l'union européenne le problème
d'armes d'utiliser de plus en plus et
ses nouvelles technologies quel type de
problème ça pose notamment l'utilisation
massive de drones est ce que ça montre
l'échec de cette politique au niveau
humain 6 finir mais alors
c'est assez révélateur aujourd'hui de
voir que tous les pays qui utilisent
donc ces technologies je pense notamment
aux drones
finalement même si les autorités locales
je pense à la france par exemple avec
les projets du drone de surveillance qui
avait été pour surveiller par exemple
les manifestations pour surveiller
pendant la pandémie de les désordres aux
personnes ont la roller l'inconnu donc
ces projets avaient été avait été
violemment retoquée par plusieurs
décisions judiciaires le conseil d'état
la cnil le conseil constitutionnel avait
refusé dans la loi c'est la loi sécurité
l'utilisation ceux de ses drones de
surveillance et les caméras en partie et
pouvant éventuellement utiliser la
reconnaissance faciale
donc malgré ce autocaristes de ces
projets on s'aperçoit que dans le
nouveau projet de loi sécurité
intérieure qui est actuellement en cours
de discussion au parlement on revient
avec l'article 24 sur l'automne or
isation des drones de surveillance donc
il ya une vérité à l'appétence des d
état pour ces nouvelles technologies un
espèce de solutions de de solutionner
technologique qui était véritablement
aujourd'hui privilégiée avec c'est
l'outil qui
manifestement violent la vie privée et
le respect de la de tout un chacun donc
on a un vrai un vrai souci parce que
même les mêmes les états aujourd'hui ne
respectent pas les propres décisions
judiciaires qui qui leur sont qui leur
sont pourtant infligé par par les
juridictions merci beaucoup tiré valable
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france je me rappelle vous
êtes avocat aux barreaux de paris et de
tallinn